you may have never heard of the ugly
produce movement but what started as a
small way to combat the massive problem
of food waste in this country
has turned into a big business startups
are now selling funky-looking fruits and
vegetables that would have been thrown
away delivering them to customers
doorsteps at a fraction of the cost
well critics say it's the wrong approach
but farmers on the front lines told
Kenneth Craig it's the way of the future
up here in this area we got it right
over two thousand acres we met Juan
Gonzalez in the heart of California farm
country where about 90% of America's
cauliflower is harvested every year but
he says until recent years his farms
were also the site of a staggering
amount of food waste 10 million pounds a
year 10 million pounds 10 million pounds
a year vegetables that never made it to
store shelves rejected simply for
looking a little different
cauliflower historically everybody knows
cauliflower is being white but in order
to keep organic cauliflower white you
got to come in break the leaves or tie
the leaves keep the Sun from hitting
this head of cauliflower so a store will
say this is a little bit too yellow for
me yellow up top we can't take it we
can't take it Wow USDA guidelines
separate vegetables into grades based on
things like size and color
and large volume retailers including
supermarkets often follow those strict
beauty standards that's led to 10
million tons of cosmetically imperfect
or unharvested food lost each year so
this is the perfect one right here this
is the imperfect this is the imperfect
perfectly good cauliflower to me some
flaws are easier to see than others so
carrots they grow underground so if you
hit a hard spot they tend to turn to and
twist and grow a little bit uneven so
there's nothing wrong with them they
just look funky I think they look pretty
gnarly they're funky you're gonna get
peaches plums nectarines but one man's
trash has become another man's treasure
revenge Esler who saw imperfect
produce as the perfect recipe and name
for a new business model when you found
it in perfect produce what was the goal
the goal was really to fix up part of
the food system starting with produce
and then eventually moving you know into
the wider food system we could solve the
environmental impact of all the food go
to waste we can make food more
affordable for people and we could start
to take a small a small bite out of this
whole problem of food deserts or we
could actually deliver healthy produce
to people for more affordable in the
grocery store the funny story I always
tell that peppers is you know to be
great a it has to be able to stand on
its own two feet so something that's a
little bit like misshapen like this and
you know can't stand up on its own or
has a little bit of scarring it's not
gonna make it to a supermarket his
company is an offshoot of the food
recovery Network a student-led movement
he started with a friend in college we
noticed there was a huge amount of food
go to waste in our dining halls from
these giant buffets at the same time
there was hunger in the community and so
we started a student organization and
take that food from the dining halls and
donated to homeless shelters meal sites
in the community and it turned into
actually the largest student movement
against hunger in four years the
doorstep delivery service has expanded
to more than 30 markets and over 200,000
customers including Caroline devons home
in Cambridge Massachusetts lemons and
where is the imperfection here good
question in my experience the food has
been just as good as grocery store
quality when I look for the
imperfections I'm like is it really just
fine and it's a great price the mother
of two says it's not only saving her
money but also trips to the store it's
nice to think that there's a very small
consumer impact that I can make just
just choosing these vegetables versus
you know choosing the very beautiful
vegetables at the grocery store the ugly
produce movement has grown into a
competitive field with companies like
Misfits market and hungry harvest all
fighting for a share it's also ignited a
debate skeptics pointing out that more
than 80% of food waste each year comes
from consumers at homes businesses and
restaurants there's no a silver
to any of these problems like food waste
6 billion pounds of food never making it
do a human mouth that's in any form
that's you know after the food banks
which we love I've taken you know Britta
says after the salsas the juices and the
jams and on thousands of acres at
lakeside organic gardens where one
Gonzalez's team grows more than 50
different vegetable varieties the rescue
efforts have been a game-changer
profitability has gone up our employees
production numbers have gone up the
fields harvest numbers have gone up
everything has gone up and so it's not
only helped the bottom line here but
we're talking about an entire industry
particularly in the state that that's
benefiting from this that is correct if
we could turn all that around California
could pretty much end world hunger you
feel that way that's how much product
gets left behind the company in our
story and perfect food says it has
already saved about 80 million pounds of
food so far and they recently expanded
beyond fruits and vegetables to include
other grocery items that would have gone
to waste
prices of course vary depending on what
company you use and what you order but
some of the boxes start as low as $15
and that's a lot cheaper than the
grocery store or a farmers market it's
an awesome idea but let's fact check
that the man said that California could
end world hunger and that's what these
food waste advocates say as well if we
used all of the food that we produce in
this country we could solve world hunger
it's not it's not a supply issue it's a
distribution issue Wow try to constantly
find ways yeah something out of it I
just have to say I've seen plenty of
imperfect foods from my local
supermarkets so somebody's not bother